wow jesus what the hell man still in
control no overwhelming feelings of rage
no a normal amount of rage you do revert
back to gen 4 when you sleep was the air
horn really necessary for comedy
absolutely
this is a multi-year journey you're
about to embark on
who's your best friend mickey
spandex
spandex is your best friend
being a hulk asks for balance
you have so much more to learn
yes
so i'm clearly nailing it at all these
things
if you want to go back to life as a
lawyer i i respect that
he doesn't mean that
more and more eccentric superhumans are
coming out of the woodwork
we are going to launch a division for
them and i want the she-hulk to be the
face of
jennifer wolves
namaste
i have a serious conflict of interest
this man tried to kill my cousin bruce
yeah that's quite all right oh
[Music]
people only care because i'm
representing emil bonski i think they
care cause they're like hey that girl's
green
jen do your thing good i really like
this outfit
i'm not proud of this
miss walters we answered to a higher
power our universe is on the edge of a
precipice
i am a lawyer
we do things by the book
the book of the shanty no the book of
american
uh laws
[Music]
whether you like it or not you're now a
superhero
let's do this
you know that friend you had in high
school
who was way cooler than you were
attractive got all the attention from
everyone
[Music]
hello
i think i'm jealous is that what i'm
feeling
[Music]
you